[Music]
i just want people to think we were
frozen
i want people to think their digital
issues going on yes hold on i gotta get
more pipes in the back here he's trying
to [ __ ] inject a little mirth into
this mirthless day uh hey everybody
welcome to fat man beyond i'm kevin
smith i'm mark bernardi hey
ho
um
kids
you know we don't cover the [ __ ] real
news we cover
the news that's
not news but news to
us uh to mark said right before we went
perhaps it's time for some trivial news
and that's what we're bringing in
tonight we're not going to touch on
other things we know there's a big world
out there and things are going on but
for right here kids we're going to we're
going to talk about fun stuff we're
going to talk about
all the movies that are coming the tv
shows
[ __ ] the culture that pops and
whatnot and try to just leave
the real world out there would you agree
mark
tonight that's the plan
tonight we can
we all know
we all know what's happening in the
world we all know the things that are
potentially not happening or things that
are being raised and things that are
being stricken down but
we're gonna do some uh
some uninspired ad copy reads
we're gonna talk about some moon night
perhaps
[Music]
and we are going to get into some news
all the news that you can use
and i'm gonna go home happy
um we're here streaming tonight kids uh
from our uh respective places of are you
home or are you at the office i'm on a
beanstalk kevin look at you [ __ ]
people
look out for those giants man we've got
gooses up there like golden eggs f5 oh
fum if you hear that
[ __ ] run dude that means a giant's
about to [ __ ] off the beanstalk
it's raining mud
um we're uh home because uh tonight kids
since it's may 3rd
scum and villainy cantina
is in a uh state
of readiness they're getting prepared
for tomorrow of course as a national
holiday
may the fourth may the fourth be with
you star wars day
so
the cantina being the cantina
uh it's a big day for them so rather
than monopolize the plays up until
you know 10 o'clock or midnight tonight
with with fat man beyond nonsense uh we
decided to do it from home and give old
jc a break you there banff man you want
to talk about star wars day tomorrow
banff
there he is bambing weapon jc everybody
tell me what you're doing on star wars
day uh we've got
uh jett lucas and uh
elliot sirota who's a mega mega star
wars fan running star wars trivia
tomorrow at 11 a.m
we've got a special cocktail menu uh
with
qui-gon gin and juice that's no
moonshine and a bunch of other
fun drinks like that
that's no
moonshine that's cute
um if you're not
in la
um i'm gonna be on ktla at 7 30 in the
morning
talking about
midichlorians and
who would win in a fight and may the
fourth
are you talking to sam
uh you know i j i don't know
are you zooming in or are you going in
uh i'm zooming in from the cantina
and then uh probably talking to sam
ruben probably gonna ask you about stars
you're gonna have so much business tell
them how
[ __ ] crazy crowded it gets there on
may the 4th it's pretty crazy i mean
it's been
you know two years last year we were
open on may the 4th but there was all
sorts of coveted
capacity restrictions and things
yeah but you shift cars right like
people drove up picked up blue jeans
yeah
20. uh 2020 and 2021 we did that we're
gonna do that again in 2022.
um in 2019 which was the last like real
year we were around uh we opened at 6 00
a.m and we had 60 people waiting to get
in at 6 a.m on may the 4th
uh wow
in the morning in the morning yeah we
were open from 6am till 2 a.m
and then we had
no judgment on those that want to imbibe
that early as a waking baker i fully
support that
sort of thing particularly if it's not a
regular activity right it's only on may
the fourth they're like i'm gonna get my
[ __ ] that's not a moonshine on by
eleven o'clock god damn it i think we're
doing
we were doing mimosas back then
at that early hour
uh tomorrow we are open at
10 a.m we're not going as crazy because
it's a weekday
um but if you want to uh if you're still
doing the work from home thing
you might as well be working from scum
and villainy that's kind of like home
for geeks everywhere
um you think you'll have a line tomorrow
people get in
uh probably a few people um i i expect
it not to pick up probably until
mid-afternoon but we'll probably be busy
i think people are gonna always people
always show up for our star wars trivia
um i was talking to jordan today who
runs our company
uh mrs jason muse jordan monsanto
and um we were talking about like um how
happy we were for you like you know jc's
bar
could have [ __ ] perished during the
pandemic um we held on and
when the world kind of reopened
like
he it surged for him um so like the bar
is going great
he's got this other gig where he shoots
things all the time for like the
hollywood reporter and all these places
and whatnot
um he's got the [ __ ] kid you know
yeah maybe one day he'll marry his lady
but other than that everything is just
coming up
milhouse for jc
and um jordan wrote something like you
know good things happen to good people i
was like
man tomorrow he's going to be inundated
um i'm happy for you uh this this day
every year man it's
it's huge for the cantina it's a lot of
fun i mean it is
the geeky
holiday is the the the
the it's christmas for geeks you know
true and then last night
sunday night was no monday night i had a
show at the troubadour for the netflix
as a
joke festival i was one of those uh i
was i was a joke
i was one of the jokes in that festival
um the joke was that i was even included
but i was flattered uh my show was at
the troubadour it was sold out it sold
out very quickly and they were like you
wanted another show i was like [ __ ] no
i take the easy win man like no way
so
we had a show at the troubadour and then
afterwards there were a bunch of people
who were members of that kevin smith
club
um which if you want to join that kevin
smithclub.com who were like hey can we
have a meet up like we've had meetups on
the east coast it's mod castle for club
members only
so i reached out to jc and i was like
hey man can we come to the bar
like at 10 o'clock after the troubadour
show and probably be about 20 25 people
or something like that and we can shoot
you know the conversation that i have
like we did at spot castle we call it
that kevin smith club state of the union
and i just wind up interviewing the
members of the club
and so jc was like yeah man monday is 10
o'clock [ __ ] dead yeah we could
totally hook that up for it
and then yesterday was the perfect storm
man because the dr strange premiere
happened
um right in town at the el cap down the
street
uh and of course mark and i were invited
man like
like what did we do why can't we get how
come the only time i get invited to a
marvel thing is when chris hemsworth is
like you won't be my dick and i'm like
yeah
i can't get in otherwise
i know like we're going to spend a
decent chunk of whatever whenever the
next show is sucking doctor strange's
dick for a while
we can't go i see the people that do go
too man i was watching the premiere and
i'm like
well what about but why not well we've
said nice whatever in any event i ain't
in it for the free graph i would just
like to see the [ __ ] movie early
that's all
um
so apparently the doctor strange mirror
was going on and there were a sea of
cosplayers
who then after the you know premiere
began they went into the movie theater
and the movie began and [ __ ] everybody
outside [ __ ] off
they descended upon
scum and villainy man
it was packed last night
and jc like moved
the cosplayers to the porch for an hour
while we did our thing and then moved
everybody back in how late were you open
last night 2 a.m
look at that [ __ ] man wow
it's like monday night's not busy come
on in we'll totally be able to host you
you are the sam malone of this [ __ ] man
just [ __ ] bar owning son of a [ __ ]
man like
[ __ ] awesome
i'm just happy none of the wanda
maximoffs that were there went crazy
there was like true seven or eight
scarlet um and they haven't seen
uh doctor strange yet so they don't know
no they did though the people who came
those people who came to the bar had
been to the premiere were invited in so
all we need to do is cosplay and maybe
were they giving any spoilers wait
if if me and mark had dressed up like
wanda we could have went to the premiere
that's all those they invite cosplayers
all the time
see maybe we got to do this show and
costume this you know how like
nate gonzalez does our artwork every
week this week it's evil dead based and
stuff maybe we just gotta take those
designs
and dress like these [ __ ] so that we
get
we get in to see these movies
you know just a day or two early
i mean
we would we would end up cosplaying and
they still wouldn't notice
we would just be the schmucks in costume
cosplay as [ __ ] silent bob
i got an outfit looks just like the
[ __ ] thing screen used it cost me a
fortune exactly
um so yeah all those cats would anybody
give you any spoilers in the bar about
doctor strange i can't wait man shit's
right around the corner
if i wasn't going back to jersey i go to
jersey on wednesday because on saturday
and sunday
we have jane salabab secret stash silver
anniversary bash tickets at seasmod.com
if you want to join us so we're heading
back uh wednesday night for thursday
morning
and so i'm not going to be able to get
to see it deacon was setting up a
screening
for us 40x we could have been in them
[ __ ] chairs watching dr strick
but i'm gonna be catching it back east
uh for damn sure man earliest possible
show maybe the late show on thursday
night or something yes and i'm going
do you have anybody for you jc no the
only thing i heard was
that
despite all the leaks like we all know
patrick stewart showing up he was on the
red carpet what no yeah we all know that
he just didn't even hide him in the
trailer now he's like we'll see what
kind of doctor stranger and they showed
that there
from the cartoons yeah
but uh
everybody i talked to was like i was
surprised at
how many
things like that were in the movie that
they were able to keep secret that
nobody knows
there's so there's more there's he's
like a ton more is what i heard
this is the this is the bomb the save
it's not going to heal but it will
[ __ ] help right about now
i can't wait
i cannot [ __ ] wait i want to enter
the multiverse of madness mark
i want to be there now
there was some quote that i read that uh
sam rainey had given him once it was to
rolling stone
and the nut of the quote was i wanted to
do it just to show these kids how you
make a superhero movie
no yeah did the old gunslinger [ __ ]
come out uh one last time
one last time i asked now they're gonna
let this guy do anything he wants he's
that you know
sam
was all over the map in terms of
directing and creativity and whatnot now
i bet you could be a marvel guy for the
next like 10 years straight
kevin foggy gonna keep him on lockdown
um you know he's in many ways the
perfect marvel director
i think of all the different styles
of films that sam raimi has done over
the years man and like that's he's done
funny he's done actiony he's done uh
intense horror drama
say which one westerns
westerns so you combine all that that's
like the [ __ ] recipe of a marvel
movie for heaven's sake so
i'm not surprised i saw a lot of good
notices for the movie people being like
holy [ __ ]
this kid raymie's got a future
um
yeah i'm i'm trying to avoid spoilers i
see some people
trying to uh
spoil it in the chat i'm looking at the
chat and there are people trying to
throw
you shush chat don't nobody spoil it
i've already i saw a little clip online
the other day
that i i mean i don't think this could
have been faked
and it was mind-bending the characters
that they had
in co in collection i i i
can't wait i'm so looking forward to
this
um all right well before we dive
down uh the whole of this week's news
because i'm sure there's a bunch of it
and stuff
um we got uh bills to pay kids indeed
and uh thank the lord there are people
out there
that believe
in fat man beyond
as uh you know a piece of media that
they're like i'm gonna i'm gonna attach
my brand
to them i'm gonna hitch my wagon to
their so-called star and see where it
goes man and we got two sponsors tonight
we slobberingly gratefully thank them
for sponsoring batman beyond tell them
who's first mark
up first are the good folks at stance
you know how dance stance you're all
about those stance we talked quite a bit
last episode we did here you [ __ ]
talk to these people about stance for a
second i'm going to get my stance
[ __ ] nookie cat no boy all right loss
at first
no
back in the day sweatpants and joggers
were only to be worn around the house or
the gym you couldn't be seen around town
and that stuff because it just wasn't
cool and now stance is making a full
line of sweatpants joggers and hoodies
and more that you'll be proud to be seen
wearing wherever and whenever they're
not just making socks here anymore
stance apparel is all really soft and
comfortable with some very interesting
designs not the same old styles that
everyone else offers stance has all the
active benefits you want with a casual
or creative aesthetic
you want to see
you want to see the face of [ __ ] sex
mark bernardin bring it
oh right look at that john bernthal punk
don't you feel a little moist now
because i'm wearing my
stan sex hat
that's the scully of a man who likes to
eat [ __ ] this is my banging beanie
when i slide this out my wife's like uh
oh
that's your nookie yamaka
um donut looks stupid and i say that as
a guy who wears this hat all the time
ooh double bagging god bless my wife
that she could look at that and be like
yeah i'll [ __ ] it
[Laughter]
the good folks at stance man they make
socks they make hats they make
loungewear
uh
these people are making some nice
clothes man that even my wife was all
about if you look you can go to
stance.com follow along and see actual
pictures man their philosophy is that
you should never have to sacrifice your
own individual style for the sake of
comfort
the [ __ ] is that all about
now you don't have to man whether you're
relaxing around the house working out
the gym or running all over town stance
now delivers its signature softness and
let me tell you this [ __ ] is soft
as soft as making love
which i don't do
the
signature softness of creativity and a
full line of active apparel styles from
toe to head
socks to [ __ ] twos stances got you
covered man head over to stance.com
and you get 15 off your first order i
bet you if you
use the code what fat man that sounds
about right
these stance kids man i believe in them
they [ __ ] changed my sex life
i know that's not their aim and that's
probably not you know what their slogan
should be but
you know i mean sometimes a great
product just revolutionizes your life in
ways that you couldn't have anticipated
before you put on a hat
you didn't know you needed it i didn't
know how bad i needed stance in my life
so i took a stance damn it
kids go to stance.com
um maybe slash fat man
um if not just dance.com and when you
ring out you probably use the code fat
man
um
yeah my my thing here is cut off yeah
same here fat man sounds about right
though that sounds about right based on
history and the good folks is stan's
gonna hook you up please
please
if you're a man who's like i've needed a
sex woolen cap
follow my lead and go to stance.com
uh use the promo code fat man i'd
imagine get 15 off let him know fat man
sent you and we thank slobberingly
gratefully thankful to the good folks at
stance not just for sponsoring our
podcast
but for giving me a renewal
between the sheets
from your head to your
socks i used to [ __ ] wearing this
and this is very distracting imagine
look at this coming at you mark
you match that
i love you
[Laughter]
this this good for you
we love it don't we we married
i lose like all the verbs when i'm
[ __ ] because i'm just
being married
is that
[Music]
i now fully expect somebody on the
internet to make a vr simulation of
kevin smith having sex
they got it they could loop that over
and over we love it
this is what you want to avoid um all
right man how you been what you've been
up to you working i've been working for
a living my friend working for a living
um you know in a great way like i'm
loving it it's one of those many jobs
you're not allowed to say what you do
yet one of those many jobs i'm not
allowed to say what i do yet um a
[ __ ] husband in the late 50s early
60s working in washington and [ __ ] yeah
just go off to the office how was your
day
you like those husbands and don't worry
darling that trailer man everyone's like
what do they do out there
never the mind when are you allowed to
talk about what you're doing do you they
ever get do they ever say hey you could
talk about it you know aware of your
other job this is your secret identity
yeah i mean sometimes they are like
we started this room
the the the monday after
um seth meyers
so like
you walked in a celebrity my friend
and it was also like you know there was
a couple people who knew that i had done
it and a couple who hadn't and they're
like hey i saw you on seth meyers and i
was like why the [ __ ] were you on seth
meyers you're a television writer like
yeah i know but also
i have 19 other jobs and one of them got
me on seth meyers
um but yeah it's always fun to to to
help reveal to people who you think you
might know that you have a secret
identity
as a person who does completely other
things including being on a podcast
now they got to be careful man because
he'll be like we can't [ __ ] talk
about spoilers in front of him
he's like one of them walter winchel
types he's a [ __ ]
news man he's a news hound he's a he's a
dirno he's a
we're some head of hopper i'm a gossip
he's a constant
deep cut
our ancient audience got every one of
those references yeah as they were like
pulling the skull cap
we couldn't have went for like he's just
jared or something kind of
he's a tmz nope he's ahead
reaching way back
i gotta get that clark gable out of the
papers
um i've been hitting cons galore man i
was in cleveland this weekend
fan expo cleveland that was a lot of fun
um did a show a jay and son bob good old
show
uh this weekend as previously mentioned
i go to new jersey for the secret stash
silver anniversary bash
on saturday and sunday and then the
weekend after that i go to fan expo st
louis and the weekend after that is
orlando megacon
you're all up in this fan expo biz i'm
i'm the con is on my friend
um and i've been back in it thick people
are so nice
um really sweet make you feel welcome
and
a lot lots of folks sharing stories
about like what the [ __ ] that i've
made over the years how it affects them
and means what it means a lot really
really [ __ ] nice
um it's never worked the only work is
flying to a place and with me and my
luck with airlines that does
become work
but once you get there it's like
you know you fall into a love fest for
like 24 to 48 hours where people are
like
you know even if even if
even if you've done some [ __ ]
they're not there for the [ __ ] they're
there to celebrate what they love
and oddly enough
some of the [ __ ] that people call [ __ ]
is what they love you know
like that's i've always loved going to
comic-cons in con world mall rats was a
hit from day one
nobody was ever like oh man the
sophomore slump it was no clerks
that movie made people feel seen in comm
world so
10 years after its box office life when
it caught on to the rest of the world
and stuff i was used to
to that level of uh oh i love mall rads
uh even though it flopped at the box
office because
the comic con community embraced it so
[ __ ] hardcore
so i don't know when i go back it
reminds me of that time as well it's
just so i you know i've always loved con
even before i was a professional i loved
going to co we just called them comic
book shows because
we didn't have [ __ ] cons you know san
diego had a con
but uh yeah it's been nice to be back
you're going somewhere i saw you going
to england i'm going to england in
november for the thought bubble comic
book convention which i was supposed to
go to last year but i i pulled out
because of covid concerns and omicron
was on the rise and i'm like do i really
need to get on a plane for 18 hours to
go to the uk and then
like i was like no don't need to risk it
but they were very kind enough to invite
me back um to make my my
debut and thought bubble this year i'm
doing that you're actually gonna be
there i'm actually gonna be there i'm
getting on the plane and heading over to
leeds in the uk
um down the lead side streets that you
slipped down hell yeah
that's sorry man that's a smith's coming
from
a smith himself that's how you got to
roll and what i'm doing
dj hang the dj hang the
i'm doing the northern fan con again
which i do every year the good folks up
in prince george
um british columbia are kind enough to
invite me back every year and it's
similar to what you're saying it's
always nice to walk into a place where
people seem happy to see you
absolutely no doubt um and then i gotta
start thinking about comic con man san
diego is coming soon
can't wait we've gotta
we're taking over the tin roof inn
turning it into a movies
and that's gonna be our hub for the
whole week so
during the day movies will be open
um
we'll be doing some streaming things i
believe
we're going to be doing fat man beyond
live every day
like a kind of
you know this is what happened at the
con today this is what happened at the
con today this is what happened at the
con today
if yeah if you're around mid-dayish and
stuff and then at night we'll be doing
uh shows in the space because we've got
like space for 150 200 seat audience
so you know normally we do shows while
we're down there like uh hollywood
babylon fat man beyond jay and bob get
old we'll do them
there at the space so people can eat
movies drink get their drink on [ __ ]
watch the show it's gonna be a good time
i'm really looking forward to san diego
obviously because it's been a minute
since we've all been there yeah no
kidding yeah i'm starting to
like make plans and think about hotels
and how long am i going to go for i'm
going to do the whole thing am i not i
don't know but it's
if i got a place to be every day then
i'll find a way to be there every day
um all right these people don't give a
[ __ ] about us or our private lives all
they want to know about mark is what's
happening what's in the news so mark
used to be
a newsman
um now
now he's a scripty he's a writer
he's a scribbler
uh of the pictures but back in the day
man he got his start on the on the beat
and every once in a while he dips his
nose back into the news so that we could
do a [ __ ] show
mark is bringing us the news what news
wither the news martin what ho on the
news front
well uh today and not just today like a
couple of hours before we decided to
record
news broke that amanda waller is getting
her own hbo max show
the second spin-off from the piece from
the suicide squad james gunn version
and theoretically also from
suicide squad the david ayers version
yeah um viola davis is reprising her
role
you could trace that all the way back to
schneiderverse so technically zack
snyder zack snyder who cast viola davis
is amanda waller for if i remember
correctly it's bvs right it's the the
tag
of the bbs credits
um but yeah hbo max is developing the
spin-off which davis is in star to talk
and executive produce
um
james gunn will also executive produce
the project will be which will be
written by a writer from watchmen named
christal henry
who uh who's coming aboard to write and
executive produce the potential series
we loved watchmen very much so
um wow that's good news i'll take that
and it's just crazy that like viola
davis is like legit classy actress who
gets oscar nominated
the fact that she's like you know what
i'll keep doing like this character and
it allows
um this show to pull
you know they got a treasure trove
of [ __ ] intellectual property i.e
characters that you've never seen in a
dc anything and now they got a chance to
like [ __ ] pull them out the box and
put them on screen that's awesome hell
yeah you know and then she cameoed in in
peacemaker as leota adebayo's mother
right um and so now picking up that
thread
the oscar winner the tony winner the
emmy winner
is uh is gonna be in [ __ ]
she's missing a grammy i think
emmy winner
oscar winner tony yeah so she would just
need a grammy yeah which all she's got
to do is narrate an audio book and
let's let's go to work i know she does
have a commanding voice wonderful yeah
you know and she's no stranger to
television she was she was on how to get
away with murder for like nine years for
shonda rhimes right i forgot about that
uh wow man it's crazy if you would ask
me
[ __ ] when i was reading suicide squad
as a kid
do you think amanda waller will ever get
her own show i'd be like
of all these characters woody i'm not
and
here we are
tremendous man i support it i like her
portrayal of character i like their
rendition of the character and i like
the fact that that's going to give them
access to a bunch of
dc villains and heroes you know
it's
hopefully they're taking a page out of
the marvel book where they're like look
let's spend the money and keep these
things alive
as we feed into
the live action i've read a story
somewhere online that the guy from
discovery warner brothers discovery is
the merger is final or whatever the [ __ ]
and so now it's warner bros discovery
and some guy is in charge of
like all the entertainment uh forget his
name but he i read some story about how
that cat is like look i want the tv
shows and the movies
and cartoon all of it to match up all of
it to be in the same universe and [ __ ]
like that
so that's you know there's a cat who's
like why can't we be marvel and disney
at this point so he's been he's been
pruning some stuff he's been you know
other than another it's official
it's like all right you know what that
that uh one to twin powers movie we
talked about that that the the riverdale
boy got cast in
cancelled because he's official so i
thought that was a rumor but
that he killed that movie it's it's it's
still sort of rumor i think there's some
people who have it sourced but you know
warner brothers has yet to come out and
say that it's true
but
i mean i don't know who was asking for
that and clearly the guy who now runs
warner brothers discovery was not one of
those people asking for that
he's like you know what no
bro could you imagine i mean like
you know
whether or not that movie needs to get
made this up to the people who [ __ ]
finance [ __ ] but like could you imagine
being the filmmaker or any of the
filmmakers involved in that production
and you've gotten to not just casting
but the announcement
of your [ __ ] cast
and then
that means you know how close they were
to production if not already in deep
pre-production
so for them to pull the blog man that's
that's serious business that's a guy
going like we don't need this
yeah like how much should we already
spend a couple million dollars in
development and whatever you're not
going to spend another 40 to make this
movie
grand opening grand closing
[Music]
if uh online on twitter i always see
people going uh hey man they should they
need a kevin feige for
dc uh why don't you do it as if it's my
choices if i'm like no i'm too busy like
they you know
but in a world of wish casting
who would you
choose
as the dc
eu's kevin foggy
um whoever is uh
whoever's standing right behind me
in line to run that and they decide they
don't want me to do it and then the next
guy can have it you right [ __ ] you thank
you all right so uh shy of you
james
j and yeah obviously i'm i ain't getting
no jobs uh james gunn i would think and
on the
well-known side
james gunn i think would be good
naturally zack snyder as well um but
that's
i don't understand why they don't just
give him his own [ __ ] pocket universe
just make a [ __ ] dc movie every two
years
whatever so
yeah gun would be good because it seems
as if you want
you want a creative person in that role
you don't necessarily want an executive
unless that executive
is kevin feige who's the anomaly the
unicorn of unicorns
is you know a dude who was not a writer
was not a director but he just knows it
all so [ __ ] well he's a storyteller
regardless right and has a vision for
what that is
um and and there are there are not as
many executives with that skill set
potentially as there used to be there's
less allen lads and you know the the
robert evans is the producers who were
creative in a new story and just were
like i'm going to hire a dude to do with
it
um
you know sometimes there's there's it
goes poorly sometimes there's sharks in
those waters because jeff johns was a
creative dude who knew all this stuff
but under sort of his
imprimatur the dc eu did not flourish in
the way that people might have hoped it
would
and so but like a filmmaker like james
gunn who knows what he likes he knows
how to make good things he has an ear
for stuff he's got a sense of humor and
who can who knows how and knows where
the bodies are buried
that's not a bad call at all
and if you were like you can't be a
director um
uh what about pauldini
yeah you know i mean those guys like
bruce timm or paul deeney the guys who
were like making batman stuff for
decades making the best batman stuff i
mean paul dean the guy that wrote heart
of ice
one of the greatest batman stories ever
told about mr [ __ ] freeze of all
people
like he legit turned mr freeze into
something instead of like you know just
a [ __ ] joke um you know co-created
harley quinn
all of his [ __ ] scripts on the batman
animated series were [ __ ] golden
that dude knows his dc like get him
yeah
i mean i don't know if he would ever
take the job because i bet you it's a
pay cut but neil gaiman similarly like
understands television understands
movies
knows the dc universe deep and wide and
knows all those characters
that's me just [ __ ]
losing it could you imagine like
you know and as a bit of the personality
of a guy who could be that sort of
figure that kind of godhead of a
universe
and you would follow
like neil the hell i mean we did in
comic book form but like what an amazing
guy to work for that would be like a
storyteller as your boss
like you couldn't lose it's like bowling
with [ __ ] bumpers in the gutters
yeah it's one of those things i always
remember hearing stories about james
cameron who you know has his problems
and his you know whatever he's very
particular person
but there were guys on the set who are
always like james cameron could do every
job on the set
he can he's a cinematographer he's an
art director he's a model maker he knows
vfx he's an engineer like he designed
the helmets and the abyss like they
didn't exist before they didn't just go
buy those like jim built them and so
what it's like to be
working for a guy who knows how every
instrument works like that's a bit like
neil and story like yeah he could write
these if he had the time he could do
this job he could do your job if he had
the inclination but instead he's just
going to help set the tone in the pace
and that's not a bad place to be
um all right what else we got
um
remember how we were very very excited
that they were going to make a fantastic
four movie and the guy who made the
spider-man films was going to take over
and bring that kind of joy and energy
and bounce and
you know bon vivants to the fantastic
four
john watts
hold that thought just because uh chad
has had some suggestions on who should
take that kevin foggy role yes um
a lot of people loved your suggestion of
neil gaiman
uh but then there were alternative
suggestions for example
uh rob zombie
introverted
interesting choice
um frank miller todd
mcfarlane or russell cook
had my favorite suggestion he wrote
martin scorsese or bust baby
could you imagine you get scorsese to
commit to like we want you to run the dc
universe
year old martin's chris he's like what
else do i got to do let's [ __ ] do it
what else he wants he plays joe chill
and he faces down young bruce wayne he's
just like uh
did you ever see what a 22 caliber gun
could do
kids parents that is something you
should see something you should see is
what a 22 caliber gun can do to a guy's
parents that is something you should see
and that is what we do let's see driver
homage performance ladies very nice
outstanding work only in the land of
podcasting can you get away with
material that lame hey it's banff man
everybody uh the one that i liked in
chat was uh a few people were calling
out ben affleck
uh look i've been saying it for [ __ ]
years man ben affleck
one of the smartest
people i've ever met and also honestly
one of the top 10 funniest people i've
ever met i would i'd give affleck
control of it but
as we've seen ben's like
no more capes for me please
but i yeah that's a good idea what is a
banff man i was just gonna say but if
he's behind the camera
is it no more capes like he doesn't want
to wear a cape
but if he's directing and show running
i think
this guy has a chance to be
the next clint eastwood
he can act and direct classy movies for
warner brothers
from now until the day he's [ __ ] like
90 whatever you know the clint eastwood
is
um he can make his cry macho you know
[ __ ] 50 years well 40 years from now
you know
yeah exactly ben could be screaming
about getting off his lawn
in a good 30 to 40 years and making 100
200 million
bucks for warner brothers still so i
don't you know
i just i'm not saying like he's above
[ __ ] these movies because he's been
in a bunch of them and these movies
nothing above them as far as i'm
concerned
but his future seems like it's
argo
like
you know adult-oriented motion pictures
not you know adult-oriented words like
oh porn but like [ __ ]
adult-oriented [ __ ] like you know the
[ __ ] your parents would go see at the
movies like network and stuff like that
when i was a kid now you know obviously
i love network now but i was a kid my
parents were like we're going to see
network i was like why
you there's five of them on the tv right
there yeah and you could not then man it
was only three at that point and then
some local affiliates but what i said
was
go see king kong instead
i says [ __ ] network i was six years old
[ __ ] network
and then on oscar night my dad woke me
up he's like hey get up get up
network network just won an oscar so
[ __ ] you and then
love you dad
i learned i learned a lesson that night
mark
the dad's got a long memory he holds him
watch
but that was very
petty hey kid wake up [ __ ] you it won
and then i waited 30 years and i did
it's my own kid one day i'm like five of
them
what's uh all right where are we going
next so yes john watts uh who made three
spider-man movies that are incredibly
well loved this kid this wats kid
[ __ ] i can't wait i cannot wait
to see his fantastic four movie man as
much as i'm looking forward to the
multiverse madness [ __ ]
i'm gonna stay alive to [ __ ] see the
john watts fantastic four movie if john
wants ain't making a fantastic war movie
in this [ __ ] reality i don't want to
be in that anymore mark i don't want to
be in any reality where john watts isn't
making a fantastic four movie that being
said what news do you have of john watts
it's not making a fantastic four movie
[Laughter]
why can't we have anything nice god damn
it
making three spider-man films was an
incredible and life-changing experience
for me i'm eternally grateful to have
been a part of the marvel cinematic
universe for seven years i'm hopeful
we'll work together again and i can't
wait to see the amazing vision for
fantastic four brought to life he said
i
what's going on this week man they're
overturning 48 year old laws and john
watts ain't direct and [ __ ] fantastic
four
one of those is very important the other
one you're absolutely right um
[Laughter]
boy oh boy man
uh
at least it's his choice
yeah i mean as far as we know but it's
it's i just i'm sure it's one of those
it was coming too fast i just spent the
last seven years
in a headlong rush to get those movies
into theaters on time
and marvel's got dates they got a hit
they got a fantastic four they wanted to
be in theaters and maybe he was just
like i need a break i need to not be
doing this for a while i need to
i need to do anything else but this
i don't know
unclear
if the internet is to be believed
uh john
krasinski uh is going to take over as
director
that's the story i've seen all over
twitter for the last few days
in a world where john watts is doesn't
want to do it or isn't doing it but like
quiet place one and two are [ __ ]
phenomenally directed movies
i'm sure somewhere johnny fabs is like
going back in
fantastic four are you kidding me fabs
this is like bro
i'll have star wars until the day i die
as long as i don't [ __ ] you know
do something bad with these characters
like i'm in like [ __ ] flynn
till the end of time like me and [ __ ]
dave are the new
[ __ ] lucas boys over here man we
don't want to play with the marvel toys
look what we can make [ __ ] obi-wan
kenobi do
like
i can't imagine john favreau gives a
[ __ ] about marvel unless they're like
hey we need you to play you know [ __ ]
happy again and then he's like happy to
do it because they give him a nice fat
check
but he's got his own toys to play with
can we give kenobi a sex hat yes we can
brought to you by stance
this is what ben kenobi's putting right
there hey banff man's back well he heard
talk of sex hat he's like
uh i just i just wanted to point out uh
harvey glassman in chat said uh justin
lin is free he likes movies about family
that's very true
and the justin lin being free remember
uh
we did we talk about it yeah
and we speculated that it could have
something to do with
vin diesel
and it's been confirmed justin lin flat
out said yeah it's got everything to do
with clipping vin diesel yeah i didn't
feel like arguing with that dude anymore
life's too short i want to see my
children he said he shows up late he
argues but he also [ __ ] took a shot
where he was like and he didn't even
work out before the movie began
that's yeah
so those tank tops are unforgiving
i i guess man i guess when that part of
your job is to look the part i guess
they can make that statement
but uh yeah
as it turns out
vin diesel not the easiest person to
work with the rock wasn't lying
no
i now i think we all now smell what the
rock was cooking
we smelled it then but
now we've tasted it perhaps we have
indeed
and that's all for the news good night
and good luck
literally all the news we got that is
not all the news we have uh we spoke
previously before about the warner
brothers discovery folks beginning to
prune the trees
that may have in their minds overgrown a
bit and some of the pruning fell on the
cw
um specifically their dc shows and the
cw has canceled legends of tomorrow
after seven seasons and bat woman after
three this is me pouring one out for
those shows um
you know a miracle that either of them
ever got made considering
you know the big franchises were arrow
supergirl and flash these are you know
not even top-tier
superhero characters but
cw managed to turn them into top-tier
superhero characters
but like if you had told me 20 years ago
like one day they're gonna make a show
based on batwoman i'm like oh when what
universe is that
and legends of tomorrow as well like was
a very unlikely show that wasn't based
on a previous property just kind of
pulled together and whatnot and and held
together by spit and glue for how many
seasons
110 episodes over seven seasons
damned impressive stuff man oh hell yeah
shame to see them both go but it's also
the bellwether of an end of an era man
like
seems like flash is wrapping up next
uh superman and lois seems to be you
know at the moment kind of holding the
flag along with flash
um and they've got gotham knights
um as a pilot
to in development for next season so
yeah i mean it's not like we're not
gonna have
any superhero content out of the dc
universe on television but yeah the
glory days of like five dc tv shows on
at once
um
feel like they're behind us greg
berlanti man
there's a guy who could [ __ ] run the
[ __ ] dc ex
extended universe he's already had a
trial run on tv
let him [ __ ] let him be the kevin
foggy of that [ __ ]
then you're gonna have to put the other
picture he's naming dudes what about who
what woman can run dc
extended universe
you know i think if if gail simone
decided she had some feelings about that
excellent suggestion there you go in a
world where like we don't want a rock
star we just want somebody who's legit
good at the job
yeah um you know because it's not like
kevin foggy was like that's the sexiest
[ __ ] executive in the business he was
just very good at the job
um
yeah
great kelly's two deconic would be great
g willow wilson would be great
um
yeah like there's there's there's
there's a handful of both men and women
who could do that job and do it well
so we'll see
we'll see
buried in the news of the of the cw
cancellations
was the the bit that apparently warner
brothers discovery and who shares the cw
with paramount global are thinking about
selling the cw
and which i didn't know
was even the thing that could happen let
alone might happen but it seems as if
neither of them want to hold on to a
linear terrestrial network anymore not
with streaming
being where it's at so that also throws
all that stuff into disarray and cw
might become a completely different
network like just because they buy it
doesn't mean that it's like and it's
still the cw they might turn it into
like
a [ __ ] financial network a news
network or something like that yeah it
could be it could be anything but what
it is if they wanted it to be
could be what it could be mark is the
end of an era
indeed
to be continued what else we got
um a tiny uh news item about release
dates switcheroos that the marvels and
ant-man three are swapping their release
dates
so which one are we getting first
um let's see the one we're going to get
first is now quantum mania
which will open on february 17 2023.
that means
kang
gang is coming we're getting kang
earlier than we're supposed to we're
going to pre-kang all over ourselves
um that's awesome man and not that i
don't look forward to the marvels but
i i was down with the kang storyline
when it just stopped at the end of loki
so i'm like get back to that yeah so
that's not coming in
where they did the statue where he
[ __ ] looks like him from the comics
and [ __ ] yep
yeah baby speaking of [ __ ]
marvel shows
uh tonight you know in like two and a
half hours they dropped the last episode
of moon night
i don't know how the [ __ ] they're gonna
tie that up in 45 minutes
um the last episode has was absolutely
the best and a high water mark
for me for marvel
studios
um you know marvel studios has always
been good at emotional playing an
emotional note
um
whether it be
you know
uh [ __ ]
peter's mom reaching out for saint peter
give me her hand
in guardians of the galaxy or and i just
got emotional doing that
um they you know they can nail emotional
moments
what they did in the last episode of
[ __ ] moon night what oscar isaacs did
[ __ ] give this guy
two acting awards
for that [ __ ] one
that one
episode alone because he's given two
completely distinctly different and
amazing performances
and where they took the character and
the storyline was
just fantastic and brave and meaningful
um i loved it i thought the last episode
just [ __ ] rocked man but
as i watched it i'm like
how the f
how the [ __ ] do you wrap this up
with one episode to go man it's like
they opened up a whole [ __ ] can of
worms in this episode and they're like
nah we'll get it done by next episode so
i
i'm gonna say wait normally i get up in
the morning and watch it but i'm gonna
wait till midnight cause i gotta see
what the [ __ ] going on man what'd you
think of it
um i it felt to me a bit like that
episode of boba fett where it suddenly
became the mandalorian
where it's like oh this is a great
episode of television
inside of a series that i don't know if
it knows what it's doing anymore
you know like because that hour of of
moon night was really strong like again
oscar isaac is doing some great stuff
the
the whole like boat on the sands and
going into the reeds of the afterlife
and your hippo goddess who's super fun
and the way they sort of
wean and dip in and out of all these
memory bits like that's all great
but the show had been about amit being
resurrected from the
from the beyond who's gonna somehow
trigger the death of half of humanity
and that threat seems entirely absent
from the show at this point
like it's not in any way about what it
was about and i suppose that's okay
but
i invested quite a bit of time in that
and like oh all right this is this is
what the show is about this is the big
threat this is a big bad
and then we don't engage with it at all
in the penultimate episode of the season
which again was fun and strong but i'm
like what how does this
where are we i've seen a few people
reference a episode of buffy do you know
what they're talking about
um
yeah i want to say that yeah there was
an episode of buffy where buffy epis
from season six called normal again
chris bucha taylor says
yeah which is all about her being
in therapy and somebody trying to
convince her
that
the life that she her life is a vampire
slayer is a manifestation
of her own internal trauma that it's not
real oh so
they did the hugo strange story yeah a
bit a bit
well if they're doing the hugo strange
story mark why they call it the buffy
story
just just curious
it's an homage kevin i see i see yeah
you know and so that that kind of i mean
and lost was also very much about you
know trauma manifesting as reality and
whether or not those things are are
functional and operative operative for
for characters going forward
and so like yeah i i
dig it i just
i think some of it is the function
of
of
feature filmmakers coming to television
without really understanding how
television pace works and how plotting
works and how to carry those balls
forward how to keep them all in the air
at the same time and how to give you
episodes that each of them have
a certain amount of of tonnage that
you're delivering
as opposed to just kind of like pulling
the taffy a bit until like because if
this was a movie this would be your big
like the end of your second act your
heroes at its lowest point is about to
crest into being the guy you want him to
be at the end it's
it's john mcclane pulling glass out of
his feet it's you know after ellis gets
shot it's all of those things we all
know it it's it's
it's luke skywalker getting his hand cut
off it's like how where do we go from
here what's the other side of that
but to get to it so late in the show to
only have another 45 minutes to wrap up
all of these plot lines
and hoping that it's going to land
emotionally as emotional as this episode
was
is it tough not to crack unless you've
been playing and dealing and meeting out
this story
um incrementally over time so i'm i'm
curious i'm hopeful
but i'm also a little tentative
well i liked it
as well we should
and there it is kids once again mark and
i
on the same page
and are exactly on the same page
uh i think you figured out why you don't
get invited to marvel things anymore
it's because you're hitched your wagon
to my star buddy my depressing
face honestly if that was the reason i'd
be like all right that's legit
because i'm going to the premiere [ __ ]
it off or no but like i would get it and
i'd be like well like
it's more important to me to be friends
with [ __ ] mark than it is to go to
your movie premiere
but i don't think that's i don't think
that's it
maybe we're just a non-factor dude maybe
nobody knows about this show maybe maybe
you and i are sitting in therapy in some
[ __ ] office where a doctor's like you
believe that you're podcasters with a
hit youtube show
where you talk about pop culture but
really you're not
well i will i will say that at least
some people at marvel know who we are
um
i was on a i was on a zoom
probably about three or four months ago
no yeah it was like mid-february
with uh with it with a director of a
certain marvel film
um
which may or may not have taken place in
a
fantastical potentially mystical african
jungle nation
and
um
he said
i watch your podcast sometime it's
pretty cool it's pretty dope i like i
like i like what you and kevin are doing
on that
i was like oh thank you
that means the world to me sir
and it was somebody reputable or just
somebody
it was the director of said movie
really really
so they know who we are
at least one of them does and i'm like
if he knows who we are other people must
know who we are
so we got that going and still we don't
get invited premieres what are we doing
wrong
i honestly like i don't want to go to
premieres as much as i would just like
to see them screaming
like give us a [ __ ] scream let's go
see with the [ __ ] press
we'll work the room we'll be like hey
what about them donuts hey hey [ __ ]
hope this ain't a dark world you know
what i'm saying hey hey
everything marvel does is great what
about them
[Laughter]
oh good lord one day yeah
all right so uh oh batman
structure the show for us what's going
on why aren't you [ __ ] getting the
bar ready for may the fourth
i i hired people to do that
and i was there all day which i'll tell
a quick story before i
talk about moon knight for a minute i uh
i've had jocelyn down at the bar the
last two days getting stuff set up and
we have just for those that don't follow
that closely is banff's man banff man's
little kid
baby bamf baby uh who's 18 months old
she's just starting to talk
and
i'm more of a baby yoda household like i
refer to
the little thing is baby yoda
we walk into the bar and we have a baby
yoda behind the bar
like on the center island there
and she walks in and she goes oh
hi grogu
[Laughter]
she's 18 months old she knows grogu do
you roll a camera on that
i didn't get it
i was so funny though you [ __ ] dummy
god damn it what a missed opportunity
you should just be rolling cameras
24 7 in your house dude just just put
some mocap [ __ ] just hanging off of her
head so you get everything that's right
make her look like [ __ ] gollum and
[ __ ]
cameras everywhere following every
movement um when they start talking
that's when things get electric
it's fun it's really fun um but
did you guys see the
marvel studios tweet about moon night
no
i guess
earlier in the day
they tweeted something and said uh this
wednesday experienced the epic series
finale of marvel studios moon night on
disney plus
which 15 minutes later it was deleted
and retweeted as
this wednesday experience the epic
season
finale
so they changed it from series to season
i basically nobody would catch them
i bet you they did that because
whoever tweeted it first just put up
season finale and then somebody was like
oh my god like
or series finale and they're like oh my
god that's gonna make it seem like it's
over and they're like oh [ __ ] you're
right and they went to season and said i
i don't think it's
it's like we're trying to keep this
under the
[ __ ] covers but i mean who knows
there's
i'm so curious
as much as i'm curious because i love
the storyline i can't wait to see what
else oscar isaac does
i'm so curious how the [ __ ] you stick
the landing
this with with 40 minutes 45 minutes to
go it's not even one of their longer
like season finales it's on the shorter
side so
i hope they i hope they do it but it
could be that this is it
could be it's a one and done like wanda
vision
yeah because it does feel as if you know
if you have oscar isaac
then you have big plans for moonlight
you know if you've got a blade movie
coming and if you've got multiverse of
madness happening and you've got
if you're in marvel's horror phase
then it seems like this guy wants to be
a bigger player in whatever that phase
is
and so yeah potentially there is no
second season it just springs into the
movies from here
just like wanda she never going back to
a show
yeah i mean i don't know if there's
gonna be a falcon winter soldier season
two because they're making a captain
america four
yeah
yeah good point like why would you need
to yeah
um
all right
uh well [ __ ]
i guess we got done are we done with the
news uh we have uh we have one more real
story and then one more just sort of
coda to uh to a thing we covered before
the story is frank miller legendary
comic book artist writer producer anchor
cartoonist is launching his own
publishing banner
hey good for him named frank miller
presents the company will have the
writer artist behind dark knight returns
since cena 300 acting as president and
editor-in-chief with the goal of
creating and curating a line of comics
that hopes to capture miller's distinct
visual style while also working with a
range of talent from comics veterans to
rising artists
um dan de dio who had been the co-pilot
of dc from 2010 to 2020 will now be the
publisher at frank miller
presents
good old dan didio indeed and part of
what they're going to put out as their
launch announcement is a new sin city
comic and a return to ronin the sci-fi
samurai book
that uh that he did for dc back in the
day
so more frank miller not a bad fan i saw
him rolling around one of the cons
recently i think it was philadelphia
how do you look
you know
like frank miller frank miller he's had
some health things but he's still above
ground
he's still working
that's all we're looking for
um and i guess the last comic book story
is the the the
passing of neil adams which
yes we did drop a lovely sort of six
hour long collection of interviews
the great neil adams passed a couple
days ago at age 80 i believe
um a titan you know [ __ ] there's a
mount rushmore of [ __ ] batman
he's on it if there's much more of
[ __ ] creators of artists uh legends
dc marvel
it doesn't matter
uh he's up there um
it was uh
i got to
do podcasts with him on two occasions
um
one was like three hours the other was
like two
and then i also got them onto comic book
men as well
but we took those uh five hours because
all the old podcasts
like all the uh fat man on batman's are
at that kevin smith
thatkevinsmithclub.com so if you're not
a member you can't get to them so we
took
the
chunk all the neil podcasts and i
recorded an intro we put them together
and released it for everybody to
to download and listen to what a [ __ ]
amazing storyteller this cat was you
think he was a storyteller a great
storyteller like with [ __ ] pen and
ink
this [ __ ]
this guy's he put the rack in rack and
tour man
he was absolutely lovely go listen to
that podcast kids and you know
we'll sit here and and we'll wax
rapsodically about a legend but uh
if you listen to those episodes uh and
it's just up now in podcast form
uh
i think it was the fat man beyond
episode just prior to this one
um
you'll you'll hear him speak for himself
and
he was absolutely lovely he drew heroes
and he was a hero he uh he didn't just
walk the walk or talk talk he walked the
walk he's the guy that got siegel and
schuster
[ __ ] paid
finally
from dc from their corporate parent
warner
warner brothers when superman was coming
out
amongst many other things
dude was an absolute [ __ ] legend man
not to mention
the artists of the very first batman
comic book cover i ever saw in my life
uh that issue of detective or the giant
joker looming over gotham holding the
playing card and batman
pinned to it um
i always forget the number i to look
that up and memorize it
i'm sure someone in chat will tell me
what it is but
man this cat was absolutely lovely and
i'm lucky to have met him i was lucky to
spend time with him i was lucky to live
in the same existence where i saw the
drawings this [ __ ] man did
but uh because this podcasting [ __ ]
which i've been doing since 2007 i was
lucky enough to
sit down with him really pick his
[ __ ] brain and hang out with them and
hear those stories
absolutely
lovely lovely man a talented genius uh
huge loss
for the world
um
great [ __ ] guy
yeah there's a there's a really nice um
obituary from and batman 251 they're
telling me nice joker's five-way revenge
yeah there's a really good obit in the
hulling reporter that that boris kid
wrote and he had a quote from neil's son
josh
which was it wasn't until i sat at
tables at conventions next to the same
people i would watch treat my father
with such reference that i understood
too he was their father
neil adams most undeniable quality was
the one i had known about in my entire
life he was a father not just my father
but a father to all
who who would get to know him
i was like that's very sweet
very sweet that that uh i got a little
moist alright on that one that's uh
it's true i would say it's absolutely
true he did come across very paternal
um
yeah great guy he said further my father
was a force his career was defined by an
unparalleled artistic talent and her
unwavering character that drove him to
constantly fight for his peers and those
in need would become known in the comics
industry as one of the most influential
creators of all time and a champion of
social and creators rights when he saw a
problem he wouldn't hesitate what would
become tales told and retold of the
fights he fought were born out of my
father simply seeing something wrong as
you walk through the halls of marvel and
dc and deciding to do something right
about it then and there
uh doug unfunny in chat says neil died
from complications from sepsis
um
80 which
is not that old man like
daniel russell said uh
he reviewed my portfolio once and ripped
me a new one and pushed me into
self-publishing
um yeah
damn man
sucks that we lose that guy
was an absolute titan that means the two
titanic talents behind the epic hard
traveling heroes
uh storylines green arrow and green uh
um lantern
are now both past
as denny o'neil
and uh neil adams right the whole room
yeah
i'm i've talked to both of them for
family and beyond
wonderful wonderful people
we'll rest in peace neil
thank you for your time your talent
thank you for making us believe in this
[ __ ] believe in superheroes
uh thanks for drawing him so [ __ ]
wickedly
um
and thank you for always preaching the
gospel he sold the game
his whole life he never turned his back
on comics
great [ __ ] dude
yeah and you know doing doing what he
did for steven schuster making sure that
they got some money they got a pension
from dc warner brothers for their work
um
this is a guy who recognized like
we're in the superhero business and they
created the original superhero
like
they're chairman emeritus to this
[ __ ] [ __ ] give them what's right man
don't matter that they
did it as a work for hire like are you
[ __ ] kidding me you're about to open
a movie that's going to make millions of
dollars
and he shamed them into [ __ ] backing
you know and backing
down and giving [ __ ] money
to the guys who literally birthed the
super heroics genre no superheroes
before superman kids
so
neil made sure that
the person responsible for every [ __ ]
story you love at the root of it
got their
eventual due after decades of poor
treatment
yeah that's a [ __ ] hero man
he could draw him and he was one neil
adams jeff's kiss
big bucket of wind as we say on
babylon
indeed
that's the news my friend there it is
man there's the news ladies and
gentlemen mark brought to the news uh
that's going to bring us to the second
half of our show
there's another ad kid there is indeed
the good folks at native you've talked
you've heard us talk about how much we
love native the thoughtful formulation
behind their product is something that
we have always loved because they
understand that it's not just what's on
the inside that counts but on the
outside that's why native is releasing
their deodorant that i know and love
that we know and loving new and improved
plastic free packaging
uh native kids uh these folks have been
sponsors of fat man beyond
uh for a while now and we're big
fans of native i literally see native
products every day in my shower and not
because they send them to me for free um
because as i've reported many times
my wife uses them um we went away it was
weird we went away for like a week and
came back and all her native products
were gone
and we honestly can't figure out what
the [ __ ] happened to them
so she went out and quickly replaced
them uh follow along with uh with us at
uh native
deo.com
fat man that's native deo dot com slash
fat man man where you could use the
promo code fat man at checkout and get
20 percent of your off your first order
that's nativedeo.com
fatman and use promo code fatman at
checkout for 20 off your first order but
these native cats
make a fine [ __ ] product man it's all
natural and [ __ ] vegan even so if you're
one of those weird vegan people like
myself
um you could use the product proudly or
eat it i don't suggest doing that
and native tells us every week please
stop [ __ ] doing that
it's not funny
and b it's it's just not right you can't
eat this [ __ ] i'm like yeah well then
you shouldn't make it taste so [ __ ]
good it shouldn't smell like cookies and
candy canes like during the holidays um
what flavor is they doing now mark
uh let's see now you can choose from 10
cents including their classic coconut
and vanilla incense this shit's worth at
least a dollar take it back
thank you
yes they got tie-dye vanilla cupcake
mint cookie cupcake fresh peach cupcake
very much over the cupcakes and ginger
lemonade cupcake that's some delicious
[ __ ] deodorant who don't want to
[ __ ] smell like that why do you want
to smell bad you smelly piece of [ __ ] go
to nativedeo.com
fat man get some of that tasty smelling
[ __ ] all over your body man your head
your hair you wash your your
naked parts with it
it's good times man sphincter well
that's too deep your [ __ ]
uh
smelling right yeah man keep it fresh
with native
taint yours and taint mines natives
that little strip of land right between
the areas belongs to native that's
native country
you've heard of market cupcake you've
heard of marlboro country this is native
country it's down there it's very small
it's like new zealand
it's below australia the
whole metaphor is falling apart the
point is this kids
nativedeo.com fat man you make an order
they can give you 20 off
that's that's how good these people are
not only they make a fine [ __ ]
product that smells amazing they're
going to give you a little loot off man
for being a first-time customer and [ __ ]
go to nativedeo.com
fat man kids and uh do some business
with our friends over at native show
them your love
um the way they show us love all the
time by doing an ad right here on fat
man beyond one
longest sponsor i think we've ever had i
think you're right i think you're right
so again taint misbehavin
with native deo.com hey they are they
gotta hire you as a copywriter
do you need more puns good folks native
we thank the good folks at native for uh
for continued sponsorship
of fat man beyond the uh
you know um
right now whoever does the breakdown of
the video
they'll put in this time
as like getting past the [ __ ] ad and
[ __ ] yep somebody always breaks the
video down and says when we start doing
a [ __ ] time code skip the ad so you
could skip right to that [ __ ] i saw
somebody tweeted when i was like hey
we're gonna be live at 8 30. uh they
were like well i i i like to skip
through it
and i was like
skip through it
how dare you yeah what the [ __ ] this is
we're giving you the best that we got
man like [ __ ] anita baker
[Laughter]
all the [ __ ]
finger on the pulse pop cultural
references yeah
do you have an 80s chanteuse on your
mind
okay we will give you sweet love
all right
all right bamf man
you gotta say his name three times so he
shows up bamf man bam bam bam man bam
there he is just like beetlejuice or
[ __ ] bloody mary
um we need to hear some questions so
that we can provide some answers clearly
i'm a little bit bakey
so we're gonna get some good answers
he's giving us the best that he's got
uh i really like this one this is by leo
hale
who asked which superhero would you guys
have mel brooks create a movie of
number one all hell leo
such a great question
uh number two i'm all cottonmouth dry
i'm gonna get a water so you answer this
one and i'll come back and do a second
all right um
[Music]
who would i like mel
brooks go get your [ __ ] head on
go get your shine box
spider yeah prick yeah
um
i feel like i wanted you know who i want
mel brooks to make a movie out
ben grimm i want a ben grim solo movie
because ben grimm is one of a handful of
jewish superheroes
um and i think that there's there's
actually quite a bit of comedy that you
can play in ben grim there's a bit of
tragedy you can play in ben grimm and i
think that we may
we often forget that mel brooks while
also being you know one of the finest
comedy actors in the world
knew quite a bit about drama and quite a
bit about pathos i mean he was the
producer of the elephant man for
christ's sake he knows how that [ __ ]
works
um so yeah i would want to i would want
a a clobbering time solo picture
written and directed by mel brooks
excellent call i'm going to go with the
jm demattus keith kiffin justice league
nice
uh
give him the big guns
and let him be funny
um you know i want the justice league
equivalent of it's good to be the king
rip hunter the adventures of rip hunter
through time
done as like history the world part
three
that was a great question and great
answers
and we close up by saying may the
schwartz be with you
this is the stoneriest 80s version of
this podcast
i smoked away the 90s mark i think it
was right back to the 80s
um all right uh banff man we did our job
now you do yours banff on back here and
give us another question
of you
second question
shelbybaby27 wants to know
if you could grant an honorary oscar to
any movie
what movie would you choose and why
what a great question
honorary oscar
i'm going to go with an obvious answer
just because this week i'm on a podcast
blank pod bl blank check podcast the
blank check podcast griffin newman who
plays our orco and masters of the
universe um
he uh does a podcast with his buddy
where they
talk about a director's
career and they'll do every movie an
episode like for every movie the
director does and the idea is a blank
that you know the the director did a
movie that was so successful that they
were given a blank check for the rest of
their career right to do whatever movies
they want and what they did
with that blank check so they've been
doing sam raimi
and raymie's made a lot of movies so
they've been doing them for a while
and griffin had asked me at one point
he's like do you want to come on the
show and i was like i would love to
um and he said um great you could do
spider-man but when we get to spider-man
i was like i don't want to do spider-man
he goes really i was like yeah if i'm
going to do a rainy film i want to do my
one of my it's one of my favorite films
not just remy films but one of my
favorite films ever a simple plan
and he was like holy [ __ ] if you want to
do a simple plan absolutely so i'm on
their show this week like doing
uh
sam remy's a simple plan so it's fresh
in my mind but i'll echo it simple plan
is an amazing [ __ ] motion picture
it's very relevant because you know
doctor strange is opening in 10 minutes
or whatever the [ __ ]
and this was raymie when raymie was
trying to break away from
raymie this was raymie's jersey girl so
to speak you know when i made jersey
girl it's like
kevin smith trying to not make a kevin
smith movie good luck [ __ ] selling
that
so
this was like rainy without
any of the signature [ __ ] there's like
maybe two shots in the whole movie where
you're like well that's kind of rain me
ask somebody gets shot by a shotgun and
they do fly and awfully far away
um that you probably wouldn't have seen
in a drama directed by anyone else this
is a
uh drama for sure man a mystery
um about like uh what happens to these
trio in the small town
when they find a bunch of money
uh on a downed plane out in the middle
of the woods it's an amazing character
study bill paxton is your lead he's
married to bridget fonda but the real
star of the show is billy bob thornton
who is
for my money gives one of the single
best performances ever given an emotion
picture so much so that it stops being a
performance transcends into the place of
like that is a person that [ __ ]
really exists and they just happen to
put him in this movie
um so i this is a movie that when it
came out we we talked about it on the
show their podcast and i can't remember
what
beat it but there was some stiff
competition the year that the oscars
came out it definitely got some
nods
um but it it
it's a masterwork
and
if you haven't seen it
check it out it's great movie for
married couples or couples in general
because then afterwards you're like what
would you do who do you blame that sort
of thing
um
i would pick that one and i would give
it like a best picture
academy award in retrospect i'd give it
uh i'd give it best picture i'd give it
screenplay and i'd give billy bob
thornton
uh best actor well best supporting
because he was technically supporting
performance
um yeah
that's my answer what do you got
um i got two
unless you're gonna make me pick one
but i'm gonna pick two the first is a
movie that i saw last weekend
um at the new beverly cinema here in los
angeles which is quentin tarantino's
repertory house
in which there's rarely a first-run
movie unless it's one of his
or her director buddy of his like i
think you know last night in soho played
there for a couple of weeks um because
he and edgar wright are pretty close
but i got to go see aliens
james cameron's sequel to the ridley
scott 1979 picture alien amazing movie
aliens is a perfect movie like it just
it fires on every cylinder it's
emotional it's full of tension it's
action-packed you know every character
in there and what they're about
you're never at a want for what's
happening even though there's supposed
to be mystery and things to solve and
understand but
it's it's just this perfect masterwork
of an action movie
that because it's an action movement
because it's science fiction was never
going to get any love at the oscars
outside of some technical achievement
um but my god it all works like sagrini
weaver is doing fantastic work as ripley
i mean bill paxton is [ __ ] awesome
and lance henriksen is awesome like
there's
you know if you've ever seen that movie
you know it's good but seeing it on the
big screen again just re-ignited my love
for it
so i would give that a bunch of [ __ ] at
the very least you know an adapted
screenplay which is probably what it
would get given that it's a sequel
um sigourney probably you know if she
didn't get which i don't think she did
get a best actress nomination
um but she should have won it because
she's fantastic um and best direction
like again i think
james cameron's a master at that
um if it's not aliens midnight run
midnight run is it's one of the best
comedies of the 1980s if not one of the
best comedies of the latter part of the
20th century
and robert de niro charles grodin
it's it's it's de niro's first real out
and out comic performance even though
he's a bit of a straight man
um but it's just so much fun
and it's so well executed and the oscars
never ever ever reward comedy in any
real fundamental way
and that similarly is a perfect movie
martin brest who directed it made two of
the best films of the 1980s he did he
did beverly hills cop and then he did
midnight run
and those two are just signal works
of of what those kind of movies were
um he also did um
uh meet joe black
so he's the one that killed brad pitt
with the cab and that clip that pops up
on twitter periodically
and i believe his i don't know if his
last film but the movie that put him in
movie jail for a while was of course
geely yeah
no he breast as well wrote a sensible
woman was marty brast
he he had a run until he didn't yeah and
then run stopped um which is is too bad
because he was you know for for a good
four or five movies there one of the
best to ever do it
and jilly was his last movie in 2003.
yeah
he's made eight features seven features
hot tomorrow's in 77 going in style in
79 beverly hills cop in 84 midnight run
in 88 cent of a woman in 92
mitchell black in 98 and then julie in
2003 and then vanished off the face of
the planet
which is a shame because an incredibly
talented guy who really had an ear for
comedy and character and had the trust
of a lot of really talented actors who
he who would you know bend over
backwards
for a marty breast picture so
midnight run
it's an excellent pull the first two one
uh we picked uh both had bill paxton in
them it's paxton is the lucky charm
that's true man that's true he'll he's
missed
very much poor went out for the great
long gone bill paxton
um put her in charge she said why don't
you put her in charge
i really cut the permanent [ __ ]
animals
i'm hudson sir he's hicks
what's your question
private we're gonna have this chicken
[ __ ] outfit
i love you wyatt
um
oh okay that's the second question
indeed one more
i would get in big trouble if i didn't
mention
star wars
getting an oscar
nod
like
everybody loves annie hall but there's
not a [ __ ] holiday for annie hall
true
and that's in that star wars nowadays
nobody
you're hard-pressed to say everybody
likes annie hall no not really
um oh yeah in that world i would give
empire strikes back one more than star
wars even empire strikes bag is a
[ __ ] perfect motion picture that
nobody
has been able to top
in that whole star wars [ __ ] pantheon
man that movie is fantastic
just you don't even have to like star
wars to like that movie it's just
well-crafted
great flick
um i mean timmy to be fair
it was nominated for a bunch of [ __ ]
what was
star wars star wars star wars
it was nominated for best picture and
best director and best actor but it
didn't play a role in best writing it
only got the effects i think and sound
it won best art direction best costume
design best sound film editing visual
effects and music
so like it wasn't ignored
but it's still i mean
like of all of the movies it's like
um
yeah they ignored the they ignored best
picture and director and and he got
nominated but you know yeah
should have one sure one damn it i
should have won
um
all right last question uh mike miller
said uh if each of you could pick a
biography biography
let's try this again
if each of you could pick a flick to do
uh that was a biography who would you do
a biography of stan lee
stanley would make an amazing biopic
um
stanley after that george carlin
but definitely stan lee
um
i don't think i'm talented enough to
tell that story though
i think i'm only good enough to like do
the kevin smith biopic
but uh if somebody was like here's a
blank check
uh and you could do whatever you want i
i think i would uh as far as biopics go
i think i would try to go with stan lee
uh what about you captain
that's a fine question um
[Music]
because you know you want it to be a
person like stanley's a great paul
because he's emotional to to us
and it means quite a bit to us um
you know i'm trying to think of a person
who in sort of my upbringing was seminal
you know part of me thinks that like
there'd be a really good jim henson
biopic in there
you know along the same lines of like
the mr rogers stuff of like here's a guy
who created your childhood yeah who had
his own like watson needs and his you
know as a human at the end of the day
but you know he was a guy who out of
literally whole cloth
created
um
wonders
and and inspires people to continue
creating wonders and there's there's
something about those dreamers
that uh
you know we that should never go
unheralded
so yeah i think i think
i think jim henson you know like he's a
dude who just made [ __ ] magic
um
you know similarly i think that there's
also it's not a single person biopic
but those the days that i think peter
biskin wrote in the easy writers raging
bulls book about like the filmmakers of
the 1970s like that cluster of couple
and freakin and
scorsese and lucas and and spielberg you
know these these young tyrants who came
out of film school who within a couple
of years just swept through hollywood
and we imagined it and refashioned it
into a thing that could work for them
you know
and the the idea that you can follow
it's a bit like
i don't know if you're watching um
winning time
the hbo show about the the showtime
lakers
did not think you might be um given all
the things that i know about you but it
is like here here's the backstory of a
basketball team that changed the way the
game was played and changed and rescued
what was then a dying sport and turned
it into
a moneymaker and turned into for a long
while the dominant sport in america but
just be how you got there like here are
the players here the people here's young
magic johnson there's young karima bill
jabar here's the young owner of the team
that nobody had any faith in who was
just a [ __ ] land developer who bought
the lakers because he had a vision for
it for hot girls and sex on the court
and all that stuff and
to to be able to follow these five or
six young men
you know and to to a certain degree the
women who they were involved with
because george lucas is is not the
filmmaker that he would come to be um
without marsha lucas who in very great
ways shaped the star wars that we know
and the raiders that we know
um
but how they they built the blockbuster
they created the modern form
of movies that we all sort of know and
love and and what they had to do to do
that how
coppola almost went crazy in the jungle
making apocalypse now how
francis almost bankrupted a studio
making the godfather how george
you know kept the two most meaningless
rights in
in the world from from 20th century fox
sequels and merchandise and then built a
dynasty like all of that stuff is
fascinating but and they were all on the
edge of catastrophe until they weren't
how spielberg was in the middle of
[ __ ] the atlantic ocean trying to
make a fake shark work
that nobody thought would work until he
created the first blockbuster in the
history of the world like it's
the arc of that story is fascinating and
to then be able to go back and see who
they were and how they got where they
went
would also be kind of great
are you watching uh the offer on
fairmont plus i haven't yet it's on it's
on the list have you seen any of it yet
watch the first episode like it's fun
you know to do the
hey hey hey
you know basically it's like the [ __ ]
um
leonardo dicaprio [ __ ]
[Music]
screen like oh my god that's that's that
um you know but uh we're worth watching
if you got it if you got paramount plus
if you're already watching star trek
[ __ ] check it out right
um dan fogler is great in it he plays
coppola
and he's doing a great [ __ ] job um
uh at a cinemacon
uh they had a trailer for
don't worry
darling is that what it's called
did you watch it yet i haven't the
olivia wild movie right [ __ ]
stunning
it looks
gorgeous
this woman is legit man like i loved
book smart and [ __ ] but
this movie looks fantastic like stunning
it's
and it looks like a [ __ ] cool flick
man like i didn't know what it was about
at all and i'm still not quite sure but
like there's conspiracy in it and [ __ ]
it's it's
no it's trailer it's really good now
they released
i think somebody said there was an
avatar 2 trailer i saw the leak of it
like somebody was like literally in a
theater and just took the [ __ ] like
phone cam of it you can see the exit
sign from the theater swing to the frame
every now and again nice um so it's hard
to judge on you know like the film
quality of a view master
what i'm sure james cameron has spent
the last 10 years refining into within
an inch of its digital glory
and it's it's there's almost no dialogue
it's just lots of things you know blue
kittens doing
cool blue kitten [ __ ]
so it's really hard to judge but yeah i
don't i don't know man i still remain
skeptical that anybody will care about
avatar
by december
enough to be worth four more of these
things
um
did i say did i say i said folger didn't
i said yes
yeah
somebody said
matthew robarge in chat said lol dan
fogelberg no i said fogler
pretty sure i said fogler i heard fogler
thank you
um
robbie not the robots in chat says ruth
buzzy for the next aunt may
deep cuts
you think i went back with the 80s this
[ __ ] went back to the 70s pull a
joke
and
i mean correct me if i'm wrong but isn't
ruth buzzy dead no very much alive and
has a twitter account tweets all the
time shut up tweets jokes
the jokes that you know every once in a
while she slips a dirty one in there but
they're totally jokes that you could
share with your mom i heard this story i
heard the story maybe maybe it's a thing
that you knew but i didn't
is that robin williams back when he was
alive um
was a notorious
um and this is all hearsay i don't want
to slander anybody or whatever but that
he he was known within the stand-up
comedy world as a guy who would you know
visit comedy club because he loved
comedy but because when he would get on
stage
he he was also impulsive and none of it
was planned that all of it was he would
feel his way through but
lots of times he would appropriate jokes
that he had heard on stage
and make it part of his act
because he just like it it was in the
world and i didn't know where he came
from but i knew that i heard her or
whatever i didn't even any would just
say the joke and so he would always like
he would go to the comedy store like
every tuesday or wednesday night in l.a
and sit in the back of the room with a
checkbook and if you were a young
comedian you could go up there and say
you know mr williams you used one of my
jokes in your act and he would write you
a check
because he knew it was probably true and
even it wasn't true it was worth it to
just like if you think it was yours
here's your check i bought your joke and
now you can tell the story that you
wrote a joke for robin williams for the
rest of your life i wonder how much the
check was for
i think it was like it's like 500 bucks
or something like that you know 750
bucks which in 1977 like not a bad rate
for writing one joke for a comedian
there were guys that do you know 30 or
40 bucks to write jokes from milton
borough but
i was like i both find that adorable and
and sympathetic which he was a guy whose
gift was such that he didn't know where
it was coming from but it came so fast
he could barely keep control of it and
realize that there was some collateral
damage and so would do what he could to
ameliorate to make sure that everybody
felt all right about it
have you uh seen the uh weird owl
trailer yet
i saw stills from it but i didn't get a
chance to see it i saw it still as well
didn't he look convincing
like i did not think this was a thing
that was going to work but then you see
the still you're like you know all right
okay we're down let's see what you got
bravo roku
[Laughter]
um
okay um let's see
somebody pointed out that uh who husk
works points out in chat
matthew robarge uh
uh first off wasn't saying
uh
dan
fogelberg to me was saying to somebody
in chat yeah i i saw a conversation i
came into mid-conversation matthew
robart says that's twice
that kevin i think that's twice kev only
notices me when it's out of context my
hero thinks i'm a jerk i do not think
you're a jerk
um
but uh tiger shire w in chat said ooh i
used to love ruth buzzy and jim nabors
and the lost saucer remember that [ __ ]
wow
the lost saucer where they played
androids
the kids were on the [ __ ] flying
saucer with them and [ __ ]
was going in the lost salsa
uh banff
man was that all three that's it
we got no questions left
[ __ ]
that's all we got for you this week kids
yeah my friend
tight show man tight [ __ ]
not a [ __ ] ton going on out there i know
two hours in and out
i'll take it
uh if you want to see me this weekend
kids come to new jersey red banks jane
son bob secret stash silver anniversary
bash saturday and sunday
tickets at seasmod.com or
uh the next weekend i'm at the st louis
fan expo
in the weekend after that
orlando megacon
where are you gonna be
if you're looking for me i will then you
happen to be in the british columbia
part of canada
i will be up at the northern fan con on
may 12th through the 15th
um and i'm not sure if we ever talked
about
michael hogan colonel ty
from yield battlestar galactica had a
very bad stroke a couple of years back
oh get out of here yeah and to the point
where like he lost lots of body function
and you know needed to be hospitalized
and long-term care and the the recovery
has been very slow but there's been
progress
but the good folks up at the northern
fan con
have built
a
battle star galactica star fighter
and are auctioning it off
for charity to raise money for michael
hogan
um so if you go to the northern fan con
website and it's up there on you it's
like fancon.ca for canada um they're
raising money they'll they'll give it
away
or sell it or however they're gonna
disperse or dispense with this this
starship um during the convention but
it's all going to a good cause so uh so
check them out
let's see if we can help the colonel get
out back on his feet um some people in
uh chat are asking about planet of the
apes four did they announce that
is that at uh
cinemacon did that come out of like the
the 20th presentation or something see
let me let me see planet
of the apes
planet of the apes4 is actually
happening according to giant
freakingrobot.com here are the details
from nathan kamal
after a long stretch
interviewing the hollywood reporter
according to the interview with 20th
century fox president and the hollywood
reporter
um
planets of the apes
jesus these pop-up ads
um
planet of the apes movie is incoming any
day
a screenplay for it and wes ball the
director of the maze runner series of
films is set to helmet
um while the project has been in limbo
since the last film in the series all
the way back in 2017
uh continuity's always been a slippy
thing with the apes movies so we would
guess anything could happen as long as
it involved intelligence to means
overthrowing the planet so they you know
they're not
they're not sure how much it ties in
with the last one nobody knows anything
they just know that they want to do it
well there you go you're going to have
another one in the apes movie i had a
meeting on that like at this point now
three or four years ago
to see if i had a had a take on plan of
the apes and at the time their plan was
they did not want to continue the caesar
storm they felt that caesar and that
that whole cycle the matt reeves
um the last two matt reese pictures and
then the rise of the planet against the
first one
um was its own thing but they wanted to
revisit the world and sort of restart
the continuity and
you know specifically what else does the
rest of the the country of the world
look like
um outside of that particular story not
sure if that's still the path that they
took but they were more than willing to
sort of ground zero it
and uh and just start anew not to have
to like do an origin story but just
we're in april world what new story do
we want to tell
um
well [ __ ] man
well [ __ ]
we got news in at the last second now
i'm just combing [ __ ] comments
looking for any last second news no we
talked about moonlight yes we talked
about neil amen neil adams rest in peace
neil
um
yeah no we're we're good kids we're
pretty we're pretty current unless
something happened just while we were
doing this show but i'm sure we would
have heard about it in
in chat
some people are asking if i was
interviewed for the new george carlin
documentary on hbo yes i absolutely was
interviewed for it
i i don't know if i'm in it or not i
wasn't in the trailer so i can't vouch
for whether i'm in it or not but i was
definitely
interviewed for it
um
uh
i think that's it kids
any love for gilbert godfrey did we not
talk about gilbert i feel like we did
well not nothing but love for gilbert
godfrey i was heartbroken when he passed
away
um
he was very funny i met him once and he
was so not
the guy
that he was on stage
you know and i watched the documentary
recently gilbert it was beautiful it was
made in the wake of
you know he was the aflac spokes duck
goose or whatever the [ __ ] for a long
time and then he made some comments
about
the earthquake in japan and it got him
canceled and fired and stuff so the
documentary was kind of made after that
and it was a gorgeous little snapshot
into his real life he was married and
had two kids like
just normal ass normal
like
but uh he did it kind of late in life
sister was a famous photographer that
took photographs he has two sisters they
never got married it's a really
interesting documentary
um
but one of the things that stuck out
with me the most is he's a road guy just
like me he's always
packing a bag and going to a place and
doing a comedy show or something like
that but he used to bring his own merch
and then after the show he would sit in
the lobby and sell the merch as people
went out like his dvds or whatever
i was like wow man that's commitment
and when you're willing to sit there and
sell the dvds yourself and whatnot
but that's a wonderful documentary and
and he was a very very funny man very
gifted comedian i remember him from
those like early mtv commercials
yeah
like early early on yeah part of that
sort of dennis leary wave uh we're
selling the network with attitude yes
and he was also like on snl that
disastrous season of snl as well robert
downey jr yes
um yeah the great gilbert godfrey man
rest in peace very very very
sad that he had to go anybody and what
did he die of
i don't recall i don't recall i just
remember
there was the the picture
that i guess gilbert had taken some
selfie with him louis anderson
and bob sage
yeah and it's like within a couple of
months
all of them passed and he he posted that
picture of him yeah guys
um yeah somebody just sean cisco pointed
out gilbert was in the clerk's cartoon
he was um i didn't get to work with him
i think he was recorded in new york and
i wasn't there i was on the phone or
whatever but um i met him on another
occasion um that's when i
met the very
quiet
gilbert godfrey but he did he played
patrick swayze in our uh in our
episode the outbreak episode of the
clerk's cartoon we went out to patrick
swayze and he was like i'm not doing
this
so rather than change the part we were
like let's get gilbert gottfried to do
dodger swayze
[Laughter]
[ __ ] great guy man yeah [ __ ] another
one gone and and somehow the world keeps
turning don't make sense
you lose a titan like that you imagine
the [ __ ] world would stop for a few
days
but you know steve jobs died and [ __ ]
the world kept turning george carlin
passed away and i'll never forget
[ __ ] world kept turning the next day
the news is on to something else
enjoy your time while you're here kids
make your mark make your impact because
when you go people look back very
briefly and then they [ __ ] march on
forward man life moves in one direction
absolutely [ __ ] forward so
appreciate it while you're marching
and you can't hold it against people who
don't look back
when you fall behind or when you pass
like
life is for the living and stuff and uh
it's a shame
uh but it's a fact of life so make the
make the most of the moment
that you're in
because geez man [ __ ]
this dude passed away and
you know he was all over the news for a
red hot minute but
world cup
yeah world kept on [ __ ] going now his
poor widow and his kids got to figure
out how to do it without him and
but for the rest of us
you know it's [ __ ] tuesday
life is so strange
the amount of value
um that we place upon it like you know
in the animal kingdom
animals drop all the time and they just
move on i mean i don't know it's not
like i've studied them all but you don't
hear about animal funerals or anything
like that i'm sure they can mourn the
dead or whatever but
life just moves forward man
um i always
think about that like i'm always like uh
when i [ __ ] drop dead like when i had
the heart attack a few years back
like that was closest i ever came and i
got to see like an outpouring of like
people going like oh [ __ ] i love that
guy and [ __ ]
um half of them took off after masters
of the universe a few years later but
regardless like there was uh
like it was like reading my own eulogy
like i got to see
the world react so to speak and um
that you know
i got to prolong that when you die they
give you your flowers and then life goes
on
they gave me flowers and i lived
and you know it's not like and it's
sucked ever since like it's been nice
ever since but
yeah i got kind of the best of both
worlds in that situation um but i'd
rather never die
so you know really figure out a way
to [ __ ] avoid that all together i'll
get right on
we've got tough men working on it
top
men
top
that guy's perkins right yeah
keep working and he's also [ __ ]
um hey eckhart think about the future
he's the cop in batman the the cop who's
on the take
get shot by the joker
you know there was a really good living
out there if you were a fat dude willing
to act who could speak like who could do
an american accent i guess he was from
america or something like that
um all right kids [ __ ] we've just
been
stringing it out because
it's a good thing and i don't want it to
end but it's all things got to come to
an end mark's got to climb that
beanstalk
he's got to get that [ __ ] golden
goose i gotta go rub the tank to the
golden goose and get me in there
yeah come on baby come on just let it go
just looking strong don't [ __ ] bring
one egg bring the whole goddamn goose
and get one golden egg man
that's all i need just one that's true
maybe you walk with one egg the giant
don't notice you get away with it it's
even more ingredients the giant notices
that's right don't take more than you
can carry
it's true
there's [ __ ] words to live by if
there's anything you learn from
tonight's episode of batman beyond kids
[Laughter]
we'll take more than you can carry
um we thank uh banff man
jc for bringing us to you man he's uh in
in a few short hours 12 hours from now
he will be in the [ __ ] trenches of
hoth
battling may the 4th
at this gunman villainy cantina right
there on hollywood boulevard in
hollywood california man uh may the
fourth star wars day all day long look
let's be honest every day is star wars
day at the scum and villainy
every day is space conflict day
[Laughter]
um
and uh uh we thank our sponsors uh
uh the good folks at
uh
good folks at stance the good folks at
native
uh for sponsoring us here
on uh fat man beyond and of course uh
there would be no show without the guy
who's
i did it
i'm fingering mark uh give it up for
marvelous mark banan no thank you sir
always a pleasure to be by your side
jay and zombop secret stash silver
anniversary bash this weekend kids i'll
see you there in jersey
where it all began 25 years
of of a comic book store you know
i'm not saying i don't get credit for
[ __ ] but like
you take away the [ __ ] movie career
whatever it is like
you're left with a guy who's been in the
retail business 25 years man
ain't nothing to sneeze at yeah man i'm
like [ __ ] sears and roebuck i'm like
woolworths
f.w
yeah i'm like j i'm like [ __ ]
kresge's man i'm gonna live forever
you're like a pergamon
[Laughter]
i'm like child world man i'm like lionel
kitty city over here modern day toys r
us
and lionel kitty city
sounds like a pedophilia theme park
older than blockbuster i think you made
it longer than blockbuster maybe were
they in business 25 years they were they
started probably earlier but it was just
a couple but i think they blew up
you know well there's something to you
can shoot for
aim for block i think you may be right i
bet you it's life
cause i
were they around when i was when we
opened the stash let me see i gotta look
this up now blockbuster
video
show me wikipedia
tell me a story
[ __ ] you oh that's my favorite
it feels
founded 1985 yeah but that wasn't they
didn't go [ __ ] huge in 1985.
but it now it ends
in 2010 essentially
that's
20
35 years
but
i mean would you say here it is uh
financial peak was 1997 to 2006.
financial decline is 2007 to 2011. this
kids this [ __ ] blockbuster at one
point like we thought they were gonna
be around forever they were amazon they
were netflix
they were [ __ ] titans and now
it's a documentary really good
documentary and there's one store left
in alaska or that but how the last
blockbuster is
man
oregon
band oregon and oregon i uh random but
kevin
shot his interview at scum and villainy
for
the last blockbuster documentary
and occasionally the screens the netflix
screensaver will come up on the bedroom
tv
i'm like the [ __ ] is scum and villainy
on netflix and then i see kevin and i
was like so it's very very surreal to
see the bar on netflix occasionally
my wife was like we were fighting one
day and
she [ __ ] went to uh like she was [ __ ]
this and she went to her to the room and
tried to bury herself in her laptop and
you know [ __ ] she was like later on
she told me she was like open up [ __ ]
netflix and your stupid face is [ __ ]
staring at
this documentary she's like i just can't
[ __ ] avoid you um yes see even kevin
smith's wife can't [ __ ] avoid him
kids he's like the herpes he's just with
you until one of you drops dead
um
one more little news thing we should we
should hit
um our friend of the pod eric carrasco
yes eric's got a show man well one of
you is one of the writers for the batman
unburied
podcast that uh david goyer put together
for spotify the first two episodes are
out free
now on your spotify
eric carrasco wrote my supergirl my
first supergirl episode
um supergirl lives it was cheekily
titled um he wrote like the the [ __ ]
best moments in the masters of the
universe revelation series for my money
um and that's saying you know i'm saying
that as one of the writers and mark's
one of the other ones but eric just a
fantastic at it so yeah he's been
working on this podcast with goyer for a
red hot minute is this sam witwer
involved as well where's it winston duke
is playing bruce wayne slash batman
is he really yeah
that's [ __ ] cool yeah very dope so
i'm excited to check it out i haven't
listened yet but i just saw today that
it
would have dropped what is it called
batman unburied
on the spotifys go check it out on
spotify kids
i remember when they were starting up
these dc podcasts
very very cool
good for eric
indeed um that's he deserves that and so
much more is my vulgar one of the
busiest writers on the planet man he's a
good man
good man great writer
decent man great writer yes i mean he's
a fine guy
questionable morals fantastic [ __ ]
right
put on the keys
um all right man there it is
[ __ ]
we got nothing left we emptied the tank
for you kids we did it's time to go home
yeah you want any more of this you got
to come back next week or come to jersey
this weekend see me at the secret stash
um
there it is my friends thank you for
spending the time with us talking about
this is nice we got to take our minds
off of the headlines for a minute and
think about news that uh you know
is
it doesn't matter if somebody's just
like
uh
they're canceling that [ __ ] superman
movie because wait 10 minutes there'll
be another one coming and stuff
so you know
it's
bad news is never even that bad in this
world and i say that as the guy who made
yogoz there's got a lot of bad news over
the course of that movie's life
um but this is our respite this is where
we go to hang out and get away from the
real world and thank you for affording
us some time to do just that
i feel good
excellent i feel good
yeah
i feel good come on margaret
there you go
yeah
just back up guy what are you doing
man
[Music]
okay feel good
yeah
nice we got a hit it feels good and now
i go yeah yeah
and now together we go it
feels good
yeah
should we have some more words to this
song no it feels good mate yeah why
bother we got it all this is our only
words it feels good is the only three
words you need for a [ __ ] thing you
throw yeah in there yeah i mean a lot of
years yeah yeah yeah yeah
mario ochoa and chat says they don't
want to go yeah
what else could we do oh no
let's talk about some [ __ ] we saw on the
twitter
um all right kids thanks for hanging out
with us man uh that
is fat man beyond for this week for fat
man beyond i'm kevin smith i'm mark
bernardin tune in next time same fat
time same fat channel spodcast.com or
youtube.com kevin smith rest in peace
neil
[Music]
this is the cat greetings everybody and
welcome to the
aka ask of anything every saga has a
10-year anniversary ladies and gentlemen
and this is what happens with jay and
sam bob get old i'm kevin smith
[Music]